the final step of this pipeline is to
assess how good our model
is through performance evaluation
evaluation of predictive models
is one of the most crucial steps in the
pipeline
the basic idea is to develop the model
using some training samples
but test this train model on some other
unseen samples
ideally from future data it is important
to note that the training error is not
very useful
because you can very easily overfit the
training data by using complex models
which do not generalize well to future
samples
testing error is the key metric because
it's a better approximation of the true
performance of the model on future
samples
the classical approach for evaluation is
through cross-validation process
or cv the main idea behind
cross-validation is to iteratively split
a data set
into training and validation sets and we
want to view the model on the training
set
and test the model on the validation
step but do this iteratively many times
finally the performance matrix are
aggregated across this iterations
often by taking the average there are
three common methods for cross
validations namely leave one out cross
validation
k-fold cross-validation and randomized
cross-validation
in leave one-out cross-validation we
take one example at a time as our
validation set
and use the remaining set as the
training set
then repeat this process many times goes
through the entire data set
the final performance is computed by
averaging the prediction performance
across all iterations
k folds cross variation is very similar
to leave one out validation
but instead of just using one example of
validation set
we have multiple samples in the
more specifically we split the entire
data set into k
folds and we iteratively choose each
fold as set
validation set and use the remaining
folds as a trimming set
for example the fold one would be used
as the validation set
and the remaining fold will be used as a
trimming set to view the model
then we use a full two as the validation
set the remaining fold is the training
set to be build another model
and repeat this process k times and the
final performance is the average over
this four different models
finally randomized cross validation will
randomly split the data set into
training and testing
for each such split the model is fit to
the training data set
and the prediction accuracy is assessed
using the validation set
the result are then averaged over all
the splits
the advantage of this method over the
k-fold cross-validation
is that the proportion of the training
and validation set is not depends on the
number of fold
the disadvantage of this method is that
some observation may never be selected
into the validation set because there's
randomization process
whereas some other samples may be
selected more than once into the
validation set
validation set may overlap to conclude
in this lecture we introduced the key
steps in building a predictive model
which include define what is the
prediction target and construct the
right patient cohort
then construct all the possible relevant
features from data
then find which features are relevant
and view the predictive model
and finally evaluate the model
performance